bonjour cattier alors que pouvez vous
nous dire de plus sur ce verdict je vais
me le dire un qui est tombé il ya un peu
près une heure
oui absolument un verdict très lourd
bien plus que le réquisitoire alors donc
pour ces violences du 1er mai alexandre
benalla a été reconnu coupable de la
plupart des infractions notamment de
violences en réunion et d'immixtion dans
la fonction de policier il a été
condamné donc à trois ans
d'emprisonnement dont deux ans assortis
du sursis simple il reste un an de ferme
qui sera effectuée au domicile de sa
mère avec un passé électronique il en
outre interdiction d'exercer un métier
dans la fonction publique durant cinq
ans et interdit de port d'armes durant
dix ans et les arbres ils seront
confisquées quant à vincent kraz qui
était rattachée au commandement
militaire de l'elysée c'était un proche
de bena là il y avait été invité par la
manie à la manifestation par les ondes
benalla il a été condamné à deux ans
d'emprisonnement avec sursis pour lui
aussi il ya une interdiction de port
d'armes de 10 ans et confiscation des
armes les deux hommes ont en outre été
condamné à verser de très très forte
somme aux parties civiles au fameux
manifestants au nombre de 4 entre 3000
et 5000 euros ainsi qu'à d'autres
constitutions de parties civiles les
juges ont estimé que leur intervention
de 25 rase alexandre benalla pour
interpeller les quatre manifestants
n'étaient en aucun cas nécessaire et
qu'ils avaient commis à des violences
illégitimes
les deux policiers qui avaient fourni un
cd alexandre benallal ont quant à eux
été également condamnés alors parce
qu'il avait donné ce document donc cela
constitue une violation du secret
professionnel alors l'un a été condamné
à 5000 euros d'amande et l'autre à trois
mois de prison avec sursis mais sans
inscription au casier pour qu'ils
continuent leurs activités
professionnelles et je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction du policier
alexandre langlois réaction délibéré
syndicats partis vis j'y étais partie
civile donc le syndicat dont je suis le
secrétaire général
car monsieur benalla et monsieur kraz
avait jeté l'opprobe sur toute la
profession de policier les policiers
sont régulièrement mis en cause dans des
actions de violence policière et là très
clairement cette vidéo qui avait fait le
buzz le 1er mai au soir à tournai
largement et ce n'était pas du tout des
violences policières c'était des
violences élyséenne et il ya eu un
silence très coupable de l'elysée qui
était au courant de ces faits là de
toute la hiérarchie policière et donc il
était important pour défendre tous les
policiers qui risquent leur vie au
quotidien bah de qui ne soit pas mise en
cause dans cette dans cette affaire
aujourd'hui à plein de responsables de
cette situation qu'ils ne sont pas là
nous avons un monsieur m'a cronk avait
dit qu'il était le seul responsable de
cette affaire d'état même pas entendu
même pas venu dire un mot donc nous
avons des politiques qui sont très forts
en paroles en a qu'il n'y a plus
personne il est facile de fanfaronner
dans un comité de soutien protéger de
ses gardes du corps quand il s'agit
d'aller s'expliquer enfin de les
pédagogies n'y a plus personne il ya
toutes les personnes aussi de la
république en marche qui ont diffusé des
vidéos de surveillance de la ville de
paris qui ne sont pas venus ici
s'expliquer non plus avec que les
préjudices que ça engendre et
a noté la sévérité extrême du ton du
délibéré lu par la présidente envers
alexandre benalla elle a évoqué son
sentiment d'impunité mépris affiché de
la justice et la blâmer son refus
d'admettre ses responsabilités elle a
également noté ses nombreux mensonges et
le fait qu'il est abusé un chef de
cabinet pour obtenir un passeport de
service alexandre benalla est sortie de
la salle d'audience sans faire de
déclaration ne sait pas encore s'il fera
appel
merci katia pour toutes ces précisions